iniciando en casa argelia viajo cuesta
arriba a la tienda de regalos por 45
minutos a 8 millas por hora luego ella
regreso por el mismo camino hacia abajo
a una velocidad de 24 millas por hora
cuál es la velocidad promedio de todo el
viaje yendo de la casa a la tienda y de
regreso ok lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular la velocidad promedio velocidad
a velocidad promedio promedio y para
calcular la velocidad promedio lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomar la distancia
total la distancia total distancia total
total y dividirla entre el tiempo total
entonces déjame dividir aquí entre el
tiempo total
en total total muy bien como lo hacemos
para encontrar la distancia total y el
tiempo total déjame empezar con la
distancia total la distancia total
simplemente es la distancia de ida y la
de regreso pero eso es lo mismo que dos
veces la distancia de ida hacia la
tienda porque nos dice que que argelia
regresa por el mismo camino entonces la
distancia total sería dos veces dos
veces la distancia a la tienda le voy a
poner así dos veces la distancia a la
tienda a la tienda y eso lo tenemos que
dividir entre el tiempo total y el
tiempo total es el tiempo de ida le voy
a poner aquí el tiempo de ida de ida más
el tiempo de regreso y el tiempo de
regreso
cree eso muy bien observa aquí abajo
puse el tiempo de ida más el tiempo de
regreso y arriba puse dos veces la
distancia a la tienda arriba es dos
veces la distancia a la tienda porque la
distancia de ida es la misma que la
distancia de regreso pero abajo no
sucede eso porque el tiempo de salida y
el tiempo de regreso son diferentes va y
como sabemos eso pues porque arriba
tenemos que la velocidad es ocho millas
por hora y abajo es 24 millas por hora
entonces como argelia camina más lento
hacia arriba entonces el tiempo de ida
va a ser más grande que el tiempo de
regreso para bueno vamos a ver de dónde
sacamos cada una
cada una de estas cantidades lo primero
que nos interesa es la distancia a la
tienda pero la distancia a la tienda no
nos la dan aquí afortunadamente lo que
sí nos dan es cuánto tardó a argelia en
llegar a la tienda que son 45 minutos
dejarlos marco en color verde y nos dice
a qué velocidad a 8 millas por hora lo
voy a marcar en color azul entonces con
eso podemos trabajar aquí aparte para
determinar la distancia de la tienda
déjame ponerle por aquí distancia un
poquito más arriba le voy a poner aquí
distancia distancia a la tienda a la
tienda vale tienda va entonces la
distancia a la tienda como la podemos
calcular pues multiplicando el tiempo
que tarda por la velocidad entonces
tenemos que son 45 minutos pero observa
que estos tres minutos y esto está en
horas voy a pasar todo a horas para que
no para que no haya problemas con las
unidades vale aquí tenemos 45 minutos
pasando esos minutos a horas tenemos que
son 45 entre 60 horas 45 entre 60 se
simplifica a tres cuartos de hora
entonces lo voy a poner por aquí que
estos 45 minutos son tres cuartos de
hora de hora muy bien entonces la
distancia a la tienda es tres cuartos de
hora
es cuartos de hora de hora multiplicado
por la velocidad que es 88 millas millas
por hora por hora
muy bien eso de ahí cuánto es pues a ver
esto de aquí es igual a ahora se cancela
con ahora entonces hasta el final nos
van a quedar millas tres por ocho es 24
24 entre 4 dejame apuntar eso nos
quedaría 24 24 entre 4 y en unidades
horas se cancela con ahora y nos queda
millas entonces aquí sería 24 entre 4
millas y eso de ahí es igual a 24 entre
46 entonces nos queda seis millas millas
vale entonces este numerador es dos
veces seis millas y por lo tanto esto
esto lo podemos cambiar por 12 millas 12
millas sale 2 por 6 es 12 ahora vamos a
ver qué sucede con el denominador
tenemos que poner el tiempo de ida y el
tiempo de regreso el tiempo de ida ya
nos lo dan son 45 minutos
pero otra vez estamos cambiando todo a
horas porque estoy suponiendo que nos
piden la velocidad promedio en millas
por hora entonces este tiempo de ida
simplemente éste ya tomó este color
verde simplemente es 3
es cuartos de hora sale ahora lo que
necesitamos es el tiempo de regreso el
tiempo de regreso no nos lo dan pero nos
dice que camina por el mismo camino
entonces recorre la misma distancia y
además nos dan esta velocidad de 24 24
millas por hora entonces ahora
necesitamos un tiempo voy a poner aquí
tiempo tiempo de regreso de regreso
regreso y ese tiempo de regreso es igual
a la distancia que recorre es decir a 6
millas 6 millas porque de regreso se
toma el mismo camino dividido entre
entre la velocidad que tenemos y la
velocidad que nos dan es 24 millas por
hora ahora va para abajo entonces es un
poco más fácil caminar más rápido verdad
entonces hay que dividir entre 24 24
millas millas
un poquito más bonito por ahora por
ahora muy bien y eso de ahí a cuánto es
igual pues vamos a ver en unidades las
millas las millas se cancelan con millas
aquí tenemos uno entre uno entre horas
así que nos queda horas horas y en
números nos queda seis entre 24 ambos
son divisibles entre 66 entre 63 124
entre 6 64 y por lo tanto nos queda un
cuarto de hora 14 horas vale entonces
este tiempo de regreso es de un cuarto
un cuarto de hora muy bien y con eso ya
podemos calcular lo que nos piden la
velocidad promedio es igual a vamos a
ponerle un poco más limpio y es igual a
12 millas millas dividido entre tres
cuartos de hora más un cuarto de hora
dividido entre una hora
ahora sale y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 12 entre 1 millas por hora ya
lo voy a poner en color azul es lo mismo
que 12 porque 2 entre unos 12 12 millas
millas
ahora por ahora muy bien esta de aquí es
la velocidad promedio ahora te puedes
preguntar por qué no simplemente
promediamos la velocidad de vida y la
velocidad de regreso porque no hacemos
24 8 entre 2 o sea 32 entre 2 16 bueno
como te das cuenta eso da algo distinto
e incorrecto y la razón por la cual es
incorrecto es que aquí estamos
recorriendo 8 millas por hora durante
más tiempo entonces esto debe importar
un poco más para el promedio vale
entonces la forma de hacer esto la forma
de determinar la velocidad promedio es
calcular la distancia total entre el
tiempo total aquí simplemente la
distancia total fue dos veces la de ida
la de ida era seis millas la calculamos
con esta información y tenemos que
dividir entre el tiempo de ida más de
tiempo de regreso el tiempo de ida nos
lo daban el tiempo de regreso lo
calculamos con la nueva velocidad la de
regreso y la distancia que ya habíamos
calculado bueno espero que te haya
gustado este vídeo nos vemos en próximos
vídeos